Hello, my name is David Brown and this is a pronunciation class.
Hi, welcome. How are you?
Hello, thank you. I'm doing well. And you?
I'm doing great. Thank you. What's your name?
My name is Lourdes. Lourdes Landa.
Hi, Ms. Lourdes. Welcome. I'm Mr. Brown. Where are you from?
I'm from Tegucigalpa Honduras.
Okay, Tegucigalpa. Awesome. My wife is from Tegucigalpa.
Oh, that's nice.
Yeah, nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you, too.
I see that you selected a lesson about these different TH sounds. Is that okay?
Yes, that's right.
Okay, we have two sounds that can be tricky. We have the TH sound that is voiceless and the TH sound, which is voiced.
Both involve putting your tongue between your teeth.
One, the voiced one has a vibration and the voiceless one does not have a vibration.
We need to know when to use this and when to remember how to use these different sounds here.
So we'll start. So a question. Have you ever said is sync when you meant to say think or free instead of three?
I think I've done that before you.
And it's pretty common. Even some native speakers, some native speakers, for example, will say birth day with an F instead of a TH sound.
A little bit of practice. You know where to put your tongue. If you know what sound it makes where the sounds come from.
It can easily be fixed. You can learn to hear and produce these differences and sounds.
Okay.
So here are some objectives. I'd like for you to read these.
Well, I want you to listen to these objectives here. So we're going to be able to distinguish between these T8 sounds. We have the voiceless and the voiced fricatives.
We're going to describe and demonstrate the correct mouth movements mechanics for these different sounds.
I will be able to produce these accurately in isolated words and also in short phrases as well. So we'll try to use them in context.
And we'll try to recognize and come and spelling patterns associated with TH.
And you need to basically notice and correct yourself whenever you use TH and practice.
So it's some fine tuning for pronunciation in today's class.
How do you feel about your pronunciation? Do you feel like you need to work on your pronunciation?
Yes, definitely.
Okay. I think this is a good class even for some of us native speakers to as well. So no worries if you feel nervous. It's completely normal.
And don't feel afraid to be silly. It's a pretty silly class when you're making weird sounds with your tongue and teeth.
Thank you.
That improving this can help you in your daily conversations or at work. By the way, Lord, what do you do? What is your job?
I actually work with the government.
The legal department in an office.
And there's just a few people that can actually speak English. So when something like that comes near my help.
And I think that is going to be very useful if I know the proper way to pronounce these kind of words because it gets confused.
Okay, definitely. So you have a good reason to practice this today and to improve your pronunciation.
We need to understand these two different sounds and what voiceless and voiced means because well, anytime we talk, we can feel vibrations or not.
So if you put your hands in front of your throat here, if you can do that for me.
And just start talking. Say something. Maybe a phrase.
Hello, my name is Noah. Hi. Yes, I can definitely feel that.
So you see that there are moments when it vibrates and moments when it doesn't vibrate.
Essentially, these voiced sounds with ED at the end voiced are vowel sounds that will find in different parts of the word.
These are voiced sounds. And the ones, the sounds that we make that don't vibrate here are the voiceless ones.
So we see in the chart that we have two different examples, one for the voiceless thick.
And there's no vibration. So if you put your hand here, if you put your hand here for me and say, thick,
thick, you shouldn't, you shouldn't feel any vibration at all for that one, right?
Again, thick, no vibration. Maybe for the, yes, but for the TH, no, right?
Now, this next one, please, you try again, even the tongue vibrates, right?
So if vibrates, yeah, all the way up, this vibration and the vocal track continues onward,
and we have this voice sound with these. So we have the voice sound with TH and with this vowel sound here.
So a certain consonants can also come along with different types of voice sounds too, like these voiced fricatives.
So this is the sound in words like, think with no vibration, right?
Thank, then, back, path and three.
Thank.
Now, make sure that your tongue goes between your teeth. Can you read this part for us here?
Think, think, think, think, back, three.
Okay, good. So notice that these don't vibrate.
So we don't want to confuse these and say, think, for example, the sounds more like a dip sound.
We don't want to use voice fricatives when we're not supposed to and vice versa.
So it takes some memory and some vibration here.
So we practice the TH sound here. Remember, you should feel no buzz there.
Let's try this again. We'll try the, and the, the, for the sound, you can feel a little bit of air on your hand.
Can you say,
I guess the, uh, at the end is a bit.
What the, uh, I think, what the TH sound there is not voiced.
It's a subtle difference, but an important one for pronunciation.
So we can see some differences between these.
Essentially, they only difference.
You have the tongue between both, uh, tongue between your teeth and both of these pictures.
But for the voiced fricative, you also have that vibration.
Alright, so I think I've explained that and you understand, right?
This is the sound in words like now we have the buzz.
I think I do. I know I have to practice.
So we have the buzz sound in these words. So listen to me say it once.
We have this. So you have a vibration.
This, that, then, mother, breathe, and they, you try.
Okay, let's see.
Breathe, that, then, mother, breath, they.
Good. This one here. Breathe, breathe, breathe, breathe.
Good. Breathe.
Huh? So notice that vibration there should be like a sound, like a buzz.
Breathe. Good.
Much better.
I think you see fear to make the other sound.
Another example of some sounds that have a voiced one will be like the letter S.
Sometimes it makes a sound too, versus that sound, which is voiceless.
So the only difference there.